dick what's the latest here what what
can you tell us well the latest is as
you say the deal has been done the cop
president the Chilean presidency
karolina schmidt you've been looking at
so she has brought the gavel down on
this deal finally it's been long it's
been hard it's been painful it's been
tiring it's been very very divisive but
they do have a deal at last it's been
massively watered down it's not what
everybody wants especially the small
island states at one point they were
completely carved out of the
negotiations which is an extrordinary
state of affairs and the marshall
islands have released this statement
saying the text the doctor does not
reflect anything near what we wanted it
is the bare minimum I have to say given
the the vortex of indecision and
national differences that we are in and
these these talks were very much under
threat of collapse that many people will
take what we have right now remember
this is all about building ambition for
2020 when the Paris agreement mechanism
takes full flight and in theory enables
nations around the world to work
together to fight climate change
well Nick so what exactly has been
agreed it might not be what everyone
wanted but certainly is there anything
to be optimistic about in the text that
has been approved
but all the NGO said amazing they're
optimistic about is that they're very
sacrosanct element of the text which is
called article 6 has remained intact and
wasn't taken apart here and it's
actually just been pushed down the road
to be discussed at the next climate
conference which was in born in the
summer and then on to Glasgow next year
and article six is a rather unwieldy
heavy going article part of the draft of
the document which talks about carbon
trading and carbon markets and Brazil in
the United States were particularly
trying to get that to go their way and
the the smaller nations were fighting it
all the time so that's been kicked down
the road another big one was an issue of
ambition which is that ambition that
nations should demonstrate when they go
to Glasgow next year that they are
willing to do what is required to take
on climate change and close the gap
between what science says needs to
happen and where we're at with global
warming right now which is leaders in
two extremely dangerous territory and
Nick in terms of the the next summits
moving forward is there a cause for
optimism or or is the problem just being
kicked down the roads
I think the general view is that it's
it's good that this is survived it could
have collapsed it could have collapsed
there's a long way to go there's a lot
of hard work to do as the summer comes
up at that conference in Bonn and then
it's all on the British presidency of
the next cop in a year's time in Glasgow
to really turn around that's the crucial
one and that's what has to make the
Paris agreement fly okay Nick Clark
they're lifers in Madrid thanks very
much indeed for bringing us the latest